Pessoal, eu recebi uma pergunta de uma
nutricionista. Doutor, como resolver a
inflamação intestinal causada por
disbiose de forma prática, incluindo
alimentação, exercícios físicos e também
sol para otimização do ciclo cicadiano?
Olha só, aproveitando então essa
pergunta, hoje eu quero bater um papo
super importante com vocês sobre algo
que tá afetando muita gente e às vezes a
pessoa nem sabe o que tem. Sabe quando
você acorda já se sentindo estufado com
aquela sensação de barriga pesada, gases
que não param, intestino que hora tá
preso, hora tá solto demais? Pois é,
isso pode ser disbiose intestinal. E eu
vou te contar exatamente como resolver
isso de uma forma prática, usando
alimentação, exercícios, um time certo e
até a luz do sol a nosso favor. Imagina
que o seu intestino é tipo uma cidade
movimentada, tem os moradores do bem,
que são as bactérias benéficas, e tem
uns penetras que às vezes aparecem e
fazem bagunça. Quando esses penetras
começam a dominar o pedaço, aí vem a
disbiose. E olha, isso não é frescura,
não. A ciência tá mostrando que esse
desequilíbrio da microbiota intestinal
pode causar desde inflamação crônica até
afetar nosso humor, nossa imunidade e
até o nosso peso. Mas calma, tem
solução. E o mais bacana é que não
precisa de nada mirabolante. Eu vou te
mostrar um caminho bem tranquilo de
seguir, baseado no que a medicina
funcional mais moderna tem descoberto.
Primeiro vamos falar de comida, porque é
aqui que a mágica começa. Sabe aquela
história de que você é o que você come?
Então, suas bactérias intestinais também
são o que você come. A dieta
mediterrânea, aquela de nossos avós
italianos e portugueses, é uma bênção
para a disbiose. Azeite de oliva
extravem, peixes frescos, muita verdura,
legumes coloridos, frutas da estação.
Isso é ouro puro pro seu intestino. As
fibras desses alimentos, principalmente
as prebióticas, como é a inulina que tem
na chicória, no alho, na cebola, são
tipo um bifet cinco estrelas para as
bactérias do bem. Agora, o que que você
precisa maneirar? Olha, aquele
churrasquinho todo final de semana,
aquela picanha mal passada todo dia,
isso pode virar uma festa para bactérias
ruins. Lógico existe a dieta carnívora,
mas isso é uma outra história. Então,
proteína animal em excesso pode sim
produzir toxinas que deixam as bactérias
benéficas meio grogas, entende? Não
precisa virar vegetariano, mas paraa
maioria das pessoas é bom dar uma
equilibrada. E açúcar? Açúcar é tipo
gasolina no fogo da inflamação. Aquele
docinho depois do almoço, o
refrigerante, o suco de caixinha, tudo
isso alimenta as bactérias patogênicas e
causa uma bagunça danada lá embaixo.
Agora vem a parte que muita gente não
sabe. Exercício físico tem hora certa
para fazer quando você quer melhorar o
intestino. Não é só sair correndo a
qualquer hora, não. Nosso corpo tem um
relógio interno, um relógio biológico, o
tal do ritmo circadiano. Ele conversa
direto com as bactérias do intestino.
Quando você faz exercício de manhã ou
até o final da tarde, sincronizado com a
luz natural, acontece uma coisa linda.
Os seus genes do relógio biológico se
alinham, a sinalização anti-inflamatória
fica turbinada e o estresse oxidativo
diminui. 30 minutos de caminhada,
corrida leve, bike, natação. Escolhe que
você curte mais, mas faz no horário
ideal. E sabe o que é mais legal? Não
precisa ser atleta olímpico, não. O
importante é a regularidade e o timing.
Exercício muito tarde da noite pode até
atrapalhar porque bagunça o seu relógio
interno. E por falar em luz, deixe te
contar um segredo. Tomar sol de manhã é
um dos melhores remédios pra disbiose
que existe. Sabe por quê? A luz solar
regula nosso relógio biológico central
lá na região do hipotálamo. Isso tem um
efeito cascata no intestino. Além disso,
o sol ajuda a produzir vitamina D. que é
uma verdadeira moduladora do sistema
imune. 15 minutinhos de sol na pele, sem
protetor solar mesmo, de preferência
antes, 15 minutinhos de sol na pele, sem
protetor solar mesmo, pode ser até no
solda meio-dia, já faz uma diferença
danada. E tem mais, quando você se expõe
a luz solar natural de manhã e evita a
luz artificial forte à noite,
principalmente aquela luz azul do
celular e da TV, seu intestino agradece.
As bactérias intestinais também têm o
seu próprio ritmo e elas ficam confusas
quando você vira à noite no Instagram,
entende? Agora eu vou te dar umas dicas
práticas que são tiro e queda.
Probióticos são seus amigos.
Lactobacilos, bif do bactérium,
sacaromices, bullarde. Esses nomes
complicados são bactérias do bem que
você pode tomar em cápsulas ou encontrar
em alimentos fermentados, no kefir, no
combuchá, chucrute, quinchi. Tudo isso é
festa pro intestino. Jeju intermitente
quando bem orientado pode ser uma mão na
roda, não é passar fome, não. É dar um
descanso pro sistema digestivo. 16 horas
sem comer, 8 horas de janela alimentar.
Isso pode remodelar sua microbiota de um
jeito bem positivo. E olha, cuidado com
o antibiótico e antiinflamatório, sem
necessidade. Esses remédios são
importantes quando precisa, mas usar à
toa é como jogar uma bomba no
ecossistema intestinal. Sempre que
possível, prefir alternativas naturais.
Sono de qualidade é fundamental. Dormir
mal, bagunça o ritmo cicardiano e as
bactérias intestinais ficam perdidas.
Crie um ritual. Quarto escuro,
temperatura agradável, nada de telas,
uma hora antes de deitar, o seu
intestino vai agradecer. Para
complementar tudo isso, a natureza nos
deu uns presentes incríveis. Cúrcuma com
pimenta preta é um antiinflamatório
poderoso. Gengibre no chá ou na comida
acalma o intestino. Aloe vera a babosa
da vovó pode ajudar a regenerar a mucosa
intestinal. E glutamina, gente?
Glutamina é o combustível preferido das
células intestinais. Você encontra em
suplemento ou em alimentos como repolho,
espinafre, salsa. Olha, resolver
inflamação intestinal por disbiose não é
bicho de sete cabeças. É questão de
respeitar o funcionamento natural do seu
corpo, dar comida de verdade pro seu
intestino, se mexer na hora certa, pegar
um solzinho e dormir bem. Lembra que seu
intestino é o seu segundo cérebro e
quando ele tá feliz, você fica feliz
também. Mudanças no humor, na
disposição, na imunidade. Tudo melhora
quando a gente cuida direito dessa
comunidade de microrganismos que mora
dentro da gente. E o mais legal de tudo
isso, não precisa fazer tudo de uma vez
só. Começa devagar, muda uma coisa de
cada vez, inclui mais fibras, diminui o
açúcar, começa a caminhar de manhã, pega
um solzinho e vai observando como é que
seu corpo reage, como seu corpo
responde. Seu intestino é sábio, ele
sabe se curar quando a gente dá as
condições certas. E aí, bora começar
essa jornada de volta ao equilíbrio.